-This is very exciting.
They have over 1.5 billion -
billion -- streams.
They are unbelievable.
Phenomenon is not even the word.
You have to invent
a new word for this group.
Here to perform
"How You Like That"
from their upcoming album,
here is Blackpink.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Blackpink in your area
-[ Singing in Korean ]
[ Singing in Korean ]
[ Singing
in Korean ]
♪♪ Light up the sky ♪♪
[ Sings in Korean ]
♪♪ I kiss you goodbye ♪♪
[ Singing in Korean ]
♪♪ How -- How you like that?
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ You don't like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Da-da-da-da
da-da-da-da ♪♪
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Bada bing,
bada boom boom boom ♪♪
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Da-da-da-da
da-da-da-da ♪♪
♪♪ Now look at you,
now look at me, ah ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you,
♪♪ Look at you, now look at me
how you like that now? ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you,
now look at me, ah ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you, now look at me
ah ♪♪
how you like that? ♪♪
[ Rapping in Korean ]
♪♪ Come on, come and get som
I got you ♪♪
[ Rapping in Korean ]
♪♪ What's up?
I'm right back, right back ♪
♪♪ Got this Beretta cocked bac
cocked back ♪♪
♪♪ Plain Jane get hijacked
don't like me? ♪♪
♪♪ Then tell me how you
like that, like that ♪♪
[ Singing in Korean ]
♪♪ Shine like the stars ♪♪
♪♪ I kiss you goodbye ♪♪
[ Singing in Korean ]
♪♪ How -- How you like that?
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ You don't like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Da-da-da-da
da-da-da-da ♪♪
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Bada bing,
bada boom boom boom ♪♪
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Da-da-da-da
da-da-da-da ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah, look at you,
now look at me, ah ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you,
♪♪ Look at you, now look at me
how you like that now? ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you,
now look at me, ah ♪♪
♪♪ Look at you, now look at me
ah ♪♪
how you like that? ♪♪
[ Singing in Korean ]
♪♪ Look up in the sky,
it's a bird, it's a plane
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
-♪♪ Bring out the bottle ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
♪♪ Blackpink ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo,
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo ♪♪
doo-doo-doo-doo ♪♪
♪♪ You don't like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo,
♪♪ How you like that? ♪♪
♪♪ Doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo ♪♪
doo-doo-doo-doo ♪♪